[Music]
this mrs. right
yo what's up we are mindless behavior
yeah well basically we have a web series
on our Swiss TV well icon episode 50 and
I just quick little episodes that the
fans get to see and it's turning into a
movie so imagine a webisodes like 20
points higher and like - I was wrong
it started off with them recording us on
tour and Europe and then on tour in the
US so you definitely see it different
bye it was really cool going out of the
country it wasn't our first time but it
was out friend time being to new places
out there like Belgium Paris and places
like that so that was really really
great trying new food shopping we love
to do that and another thing that's core
that I just thought about is you know
when our family goes on a vacation and
they they bring like 10,000 kamas to
keep memories and always take pictures
it's kind of like we're doing all of
this and even one with 50 years old and
we have children and grandchildren we're
going to be able to show them the memory
so it's definitely like a memory book
that would happen spontaneous stuff we
did on tour like green girls on stage
and still the cameras and pranks that we
did like they recorded music
everything so just fun - yeah we the
camera that they were using to film the
whole series in the show we hit the
camera the hard drive with all the
memory on it we hear that hear the
computer the computer we made someone's
shoes into salad to a sandwich and put
it in the freezer that we get a lot of
prints we had a good time yeah we have a
few more episodes left and yeah because
on the last episode you pretty much see
like us at home and a couple of
interviews and then after that it's kind
of like we're gonna not play any videos
out to keep the fans anticipated for the
movie
we can't wait we're really excited for
that and to see us behind the scenes is
actually really fun like people will we
we just watch the trailer you watch the
trailer and us save ourselves and stuff
that we really didn't go to next -
really cool and you're gonna have a
great time we're in the process of
finishing the second album it's called
house party yes but here we go
yes also we have another scripted movie
miss us and my campus is called bad
behavior my caps yeah so this is looking
really funny and you definitely saw how
ways tractor with him on the missus I've
video yeah so it is really really cool
we shot the trailer for that and that
going to be
can't wait for more information go to
model their account follow us on Twitter
- failure without the behavior and a
second album the world I gotta see